là, donc nous avons tout en
quelques minutes de vol ouais,
donc si vous passez à ceux-là parce que vous
passez juste au-dessus de la portée, vous avez cette
ancienne colonie,
c'est un rêve pour moi d'être ici, vous
parlez toujours d'aller sur terre et des choses
comme ça
tu pars cinq heures du matin
vers sept heures du matin à Paris et
tu es là dans ta rue cinq
minutes après à l'intérieur il fait beau une heure
après la
zone
oh ouais
c'est un trois-parties typique
là-bas fermier grec ouais le  ferme quoi
ouais la chair de poule ils cultivent du poisson ouais ouais
c'est beaucoup
je pense que la rose est là-bas ouais ouais
c'est le navire que nous avons bien sûr
et nous les avons ici nous sommes maintenant dans le
champ d'iceberg
ouais nous pouvons voir que nous sommes juste  venir
vous attaquer par derrière maintenant
rit d'accord parfait
pouvez-vous lui demander de se rapprocher des
icebergs
vous pouvez déplacer le navire euh aussi près de
l'iceberg que vous y êtes donc nous avant de
vous tirer dessus et aussi entre
certains avec  des icebergs tout autour du
parc euh nous essayons de nous garer avec des icebergs
autour de vous si possible d'accord
pas de problème d'accord
rappelez-moi
je trouverai un bleu
à l'étang de
l'eau douce dans l'étang
pouvons-nous simplement ralentir la vitesse de l'air Ralentissez
ralentissez
oui
40 nœuds ouais d'accord
ici tu dis ralentis d'
accord ils
sont tous les deux un beau jeu
tu en as un une heure
en dessous maintenant
d'accord revenons à celui-là dans une minute
ouais tu vois le bateau tu as vu le
bateau ouais pas encore ouais
descendez ralentissez maintenant la vitesse minimale que
vous pouvez chronométrer d'accord allez
lentement installez-les pour
aller au milieu vous savez
entre ces deux d'accord
pourriez-vous faire tourner le navire entre
ces deux Iceberg vous avez 11 heures
oh c'est trop tard d'accord c'est  ça va
être là d'accord ils vont aller d'accord c'est
bon comme ça d'accord d'accord c'est
bon tu tournes là maintenant
complètement lentement histoire d'accord
arrête d'enregistrer un instant pour toi
tu veux être plus haut ouais
c'est
fort pour la vidéo
est fait
j'espère que le bateau ira dans l'espace
entre les deux icebergs
ouais assurez-vous que le bateau va à gauche demandez
au bateau de tourner à gauche
pouvez-vous prendre le bateau tourner à gauche
entre ces deux icebergs
oui nous pouvons essayer mais c'est euh  très petit
mais on peut essayer ouais ça a
l'air bien vu du ciel
d'accord
je suppose qu'il a peur de ce qu'il y a
sous la surface ouais mais on peut
leur dire que c'est sûr ouais
c'est pas possible sur la gauche parce que
la glace c'est euh pas assez profond
d'accord
toi  je dois monter un peu plus haut ouais
non c'est une bonne hauteur pour moi d'accord d'accord ouais
nous irons haut dans une minute
étranger
je suppose que nous venons de comprendre où le soleil
arrive encore dans certains systèmes découvrant
le soleil ouais se déplaçant du
Côte Est
étrangère
à 500 pieds et passer par-dessus le plan vertical du
bateau
d'accord donc nous devons teinter The Shopper alors
ouais ouais tu inclines le problème si tu
aimes ouais ouais je veux dire pour qu'on puisse prendre
ouais vertical comment ça regarde en bas
c'est sympa  pour toi pas pour moi c'est bon
prends ton temps n'y va pas trop vite c'est de
l'ombre
ouais bon pour moi
un de plus bien un c'est bon pour toi ouais
ça va très bien pour moi excellent
ouais tu m'as dit
j'aime demander qu'ils sachent  le
bleu à l'intérieur de l'eau j'adore ouais l'
eau est un peu verte et pas
et pas un bleu foncé vraiment clair
les yeux que
nous obtenons maintenant
je pense que ça va nous
devrions nous rapprocher de leurs
yeux d'accord  celui-ci je dois aller vers celui-ci
ouais d'accord
quand tu t'approches de la glace là un
peu plus près de l'iceberg
vas sur ta gauche ok sauf si on essaye de
s'approcher ouais
tourne à gauche
et
euh
je pense que l'iceberg avec  le bleu
est celui avec une roche noire sur le
dessus tu préfères celui-ci ouais
on change d'avis ouais Tout droit ouais ouais
ils vont tout droit ils vont tout
droit prenez le vaisseau tout droit
vers ce bleu que vous pouvez voir devant
dedans  devant vous le personnage la
photo bleue ouais peut-être qu'ils ont besoin de se
rapprocher un peu ouais
vous pouvez attendre ici
c'est Burger
nous pouvons voir faire le tour encore faire le tour
ouais et aller et on y va
c'est bien
si vous pouvez s'il vous plaît
voir vous voyez  les yeux bleus c'est bien
trop vertical pour moi
tu dois t'éloigner et tu peux
aller mieux parce qu'on plane
maintenant on ne peut pas ouais tu ne peux pas le faire pencher
alors on est trop près pour moi ouais c'est
bon pour  lui c'est bon pour lui le film
est important ouais d'accord parfait pour
moi d'accord prends une belle glace bleue sur la vidéo
étranger
prends le bateau tout droit
on pourrait aller plus haut si tu voulais Miam
on pourrait prendre plus d'altitude
étranger
je ne suis pas  bien sûr ce que nous allons dire mais
nous allons l'enregistrer ouais ouais c'est bien tu
as la couleur l'ombre sur l'eau
Glacier là-haut
les gens pourraient très bien comprendre nous
avons le temps classique
j'ai été étonné de voir à quel point la grande
image satellite est belle  sur grand écran
c'était tellement agréable ouais oh c'est très
beau haute définition c'était très
très agréable
d'enregistrer de
vous avez besoin d'un Iceberg nouvellement fissuré qui est
bleu ouais et ils sont à l'intérieur toutes ces
choses principales sont là parce que et vous
ne pouvez pas naviguer là-bas  parce que vous ne pouvez pas
traverser il y avait quelque chose qui bouge
ici je ne sais pas
peut-être que vous pouvez l'attraper si vous voulez
réfléchir qu'est-ce qu'un
soleil là-bas
euh
sinon c'est des oiseaux
vous n'avez pas de mammifères à l'intérieur ici
pas de phoques sur le chemin du retour  ouais d'accord vous
n'avez pas d'animaux ici non non non nous n'avons pas
encore vu de phoques ici et puis
ils connaissent les baleines en ce moment
généralement vous avez du pétrole qui vient ici
ouais
pendant l'année il y en a beaucoup
sur le littoral
ils peuvent entrer dans le spectateur mais pas
si profondément je pense que
c'est
bon allons-y d'
accord
autant dire à Rémy que nous avons
fini avec le bateau d'accord
lisez l'hélicoptère
oui
d'accord donc vous avez besoin d'un peu plus de recul
lentement parce que je suis sûr que les gens  peut filmer
ici
quelques détails lentement assez lentement
mais on est lourd non non je sais
parce que cette texture est belle regarde
cette texture c'est beau
tellement beau
c'est tellement beau
parce que le film
y'a un bleu tout droit un petit
bleu tout droit
ouais
regarde la couleur  des yeux oh c'est
incroyable regarde ça a l'
air d'un bleu mon Dieu
n'installe pas assez en dernier si tu
veux une bonne photo pourrais-tu aller au
gros sac de glace dans fortnite
de l'iceberg
quand je reste là nous planons maintenant nous
pouvons '  Je ne bouge pas maintenant d'accord
c'était sympa et c'est tellement sympa oh mon Dieu
deuxièmement
je pense
assez pour toi sur celui-ci Peter ouais
c'est bon bon pour moi ouais
on va tourner devant ou entre l'
avion et l'iceberg et on va
tourner  devant ouais devant on
va faire demi-tour ouais
entre les bateaux d'accord c'est
incroyable
la texture est si belle
on se retourne ici ouais
montez
monsieur
gardez juste le spray derrière nous je ne veux pas
pulvériser sur l'objectif
oh oui
le bleu puis-je
parler
ouais tu peux d'accord l'interrupteur au pied d'accord
tu es à droite de ton pied
ici sur le sol d'accord oh non c'est bon
tu peux l'utiliser d'accord
s'il est assez d'accord
laisse-moi est-ce assez bien pour toi
maintenant je filme
assez bien pour toi avec moi maintenant
oui je pense que c'est bon maintenant d'accord pas
de problème
ok on y retourne ok
allons-y
tu peux y retourner maintenant Remy
ok ok on y retourne ok ok
ok ok nous quittons la courbe de l'homme mort
nous  Je pilote tout le temps la voiture d'un homme mort d'accord d'
accord allons-y
oui
cet Iceberg était magnifique et avec le
noir tout le bleu ouais pause l'
enregistrement maintenant